[Musique]
nos fils sont amis je crois que ça veut
dire que nous aussi
moi c'est un peu moi lisa elle c'est ma
chérie je suis médecin le et rocaille la
[Musique]
seule bal des finissants
ça grandit trop vite je peux plus serré
ma fille dans mes bras sans sentir sa
poitrine juste tope là maintenant julie
a pas est interdit
vous espionnez nous fait non on comprend
rien des skates 10 alors c'est pas super
j'adore les énigmes elle peint
d'aubergines en fait c'est limogés qui
représente le pénis ce à quoi les
régions un deuxième sens les arbres
c'est de la marine et ça ça veut dire
iaquinta
elle va avoir des rays l'embrasser et
toucher son énergie c'est un parc de
sexe elle planifie perdre leur virginité
le soir du bal c'est pas sûr ça veut
peut-être dire t'es cool mon âme était
cool mon ami était bien mais qu'est ce
que je vous ai dit nous fuyons pas
vraiment réfléchi c'est clair ça je vais
les en empêcher j'embarque
c'est pas tu vas en faire une soirée
vraiment parfait on va les perdre
tu vd qu'est-ce que vidéo ferait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
colère est grave les parents savent
faire preuve d'une force surhumaine
celle là aucun bouchon de
toi est ce que ton père a essayé
d'empêcher de perdre ta virginité il a
plutôt ouvert le champagne
je suis prêt à tout pour ma fille ma
main concours décalage parfait
quoi c'est par les fesses
tel plus fort je veux pas vas-y toi tes
yeux bébé tout est moins serré abc des
bébés sort pas par les faits on y va à 3
à 1
je suis trop g j'hallucine j'aime voir
mon père qui calait de la bière par son
anus la police ont vu le corps d'apollon
[Musique]